Gilda we're here at wooden beach at the  size of one of our emergency warning so  we founded on the night of the November  cokato earth phone there was some  confusion around what the foreign group  and who had to evacuate Sylvie's is  running a series of public information  night in the coastal communities of Lima  khodeti district this is your  opportunity to hear the latest advice  from our ear commit to learn more about  how the warning siren system works and  to ask any questions you may have be  prepared for family emergencies tell  your neighbors come along and know what  to do for next time all meetings start  at 7pm 16 March warden's community in  turn 22 March Pegasus Bey's school hall  27 March clio rugby club rooms six April  pines kuraki Yacht Club  [Music]